let's collide what you're talking right
now so like sin collide if you guys
don't mind right um first of all thank
you so much for coming in today
course I want to start with and you
might have heard it when you were
waiting the only reason I get to do this
interview and be here at if it's because
of house of Aurora which is where we're
at
it's a my sponsor and we partnered up
with them and I want to give a huge
thank you Dallas of Aurora for an able
and collider to be at TIFF so that's a
base pair but yes another another one of
our lovely partners so did the movie
premiere yet is it premiering today
Monday tomorrow okay so now really
haven't heard that from too many people
so I would make a sort of fun question
before we jump jump but someone told me
and I could be mistaken that you filmed
suits like a block from here or very
close yeah we shot suits all over the
place here including we we'd love noise
I shot suits all over the city yeah our
main building is just down the street
that would when we shot the like Lobby
stuff sure but then most of the things
indoors we shot up and down to you but
everything all over Toronto now this is
the first time I've been back here since
I stopped shooting suits and driving
around is just doing like a tour of
suits for me I wasn't shot there was up
there
that's right kissed Rachel that well no
I you've filmed a lot of suits like
really close and I was nervous it like
you were gonna have like a flat like a
like I'm like um I go into the absolute
right now I have flashbacks all that
that's what Toronto is for me you know
yeah okay so my quick little copy
jumping into this project no one
watching this interview will have seen
so I hate asking the generic question
but can you talk a little bit about what
it's about let's start with that cool
yeah well the movies called Clara and
it's about an astronomer this guy who's
searching for life and he meets a very
curious artist named Clara and they both
share a fascination for the cosmos and
NASA has just launched a couple
telescopes that are really gonna
revolutionize our search for hable a
world so these two collaborate and get
to look in and might even make a big
discovery
Issac Bruno's sort of coming from that's
who I play Isaac or another
Ronna Murr and he's coming sort of from
a pretty serious life tragedy and he's
desperate to find life on other planets
planets and it's starting to come at the
detriment to everything else in his life
he's beats to become an obsession and
that's when he hooks up with this sort
of mysterious wonderful artist played by
trying how did you two first connect on
this project and hotel was it to get the
financing to get this thing off the
ground
sure I'll take that so we first
connected about five years ago now
Akash was a bright-eyed eighteen year
old at the time we met at a media
conference where he was pitching a
project and I saw his pitch when he was
just an 18 year old and I was so
impressed by what he had put together
and his poise and I just approached him
at that and said you know when you're
done high school give me a call if
you're interested in pursuing this as a
career and two years later he sort of
showed up on my door and said hey I'm
here and I have an idea I want to pitch
you and I was great to hear from him and
I welcomed him in and and he pitched me
the idea for Clara and I I was
immediately taken by it sort of hits all
the right notes for me as a someone who
makes film but also someone who watches
film it is exactly the type of movie I
like a bit of sci-fi mystery but of a
twist and a lot of heart and and so
that's how it began and over the course
that next couple years we began putting
the financing together and you know it
took a little while to get people to buy
into a 20 year old director at the time
but over the course of about two years
we managed to convince enough people and
we put it together and now you know he's
23 now but so I guess it took us about
four four years to make the phone hey
I'm giving you a lot of credit for this
feature at 23 thank you so we should so
all of us should yeah no so what was it
about where did the idea come from and
talk a little bit of let's start with
that well I am a big fan of space and
and science and astronomy for sure and I
don't know I you know I love watching
sci-fi films like especially like the
Martian or
interstellar with grounded real science
and I think that there's an appetite for
that with audiences right now and for me
personally another big reason for
telling a film about space and and what
we're actually doing right now is you
know you look on your news apps and I
mean most news is quite depressing but
whenever I see like NASA launched a
telescope or we found a potentially
habitable planet I'm like yes that's the
stuff that'll unite us as a human race
so I wanted to make a film where we're
talking about astronomers astronomers
actually finding stuff out there and and
using the real processes and of course
III to connect to a film like that I
need a human story and and I wanted to
tell a story about these two where we
lost people who are searching for
something and and banding together I'm
always curious about the editing process
because it's the final rewrite what did
you discover about the movie in the
editing process that may be impacted the
finished film and who did you trust for
honest feedback ooh
I trust this guy for honest feedback a
lot he'll let me know immediately when
something's not working or not but the
Edit really revealed that for me
especially as a young filmmaker and this
being my first script that going into
the writing process now as I've written
more scripts there are certain scenes
where you don't necessarily need like
you can kind of skip and get to a moment
with more impact so the editing process
you know we definitely have a bunch of
deleted scenes now but I feel like I
told the story in the most concise way
possible now I'll just add to that that
we do have some deleted scenes but so
does every film and I think relative to
other films that I've produced we
actually don't have that much extraneous
footage we have it we used it almost
everything that it was pretty tight you
guys started cutting but you guys went
through a pretty sort of like you do
with any film and emotional process of
having to like re think what was working
and what wasn't seemed you get or try
and edit the film that you had in your
brain the first time and you look at it
you go alright this is what I had what's
not working and then you did a pretty
brave dive back in to figure out what
those pieces were and the thing that
came out on the other end
it is something very different and I
think more concise and and very
effective
yeah um you obviously when did you film
this in relation to when you were was it
after suits or it was right before my
last season of suits so this was uh like
what you did on the hiatus yeah it was
right towards the end of my final hiatus
I guess yeah it was in March so what was
it for you
I would imagine when you were making a
TV show your schedule you know you're
working all almost the year so what was
it about this story and this character
that said yeah I need to do this well it
was a long story I mean I took first of
all it was him I mean talking to Akash
on the phone and reading the script the
script changed a lot from the moment I
received it to what we actually shot and
I was lucky enough to be involved in
that process but right from the
beginning
Akash he's he was so young and that was
scary to me I thought oh my god you know
an unproven director he'd done a couple
of things that were really great and he
obviously knew his way around special
effects and he had another film where it
was clear that he understood how to tell
a story but you're still a brand-new
director and that's a little worrisome
especially when I had so little time
during the year that I wanted to make
the most of it and I wanted to make sure
that if I was going to do something that
we could make it great but just talking
to a cost for more than half an hour you
get the sense that he is the perfect
fusion of what he was talking about the
science the grounded science the passion
for science he's so passionate about
that and making sure that we get it
right and being inspired to tell a great
story based on that science but then he
was also completely focused on making
sure that it was a human story and that
it was grounded and that we got the most
out of it because he knew instinctually
even at this young age that that that
all the gimmicks and the science and the
special effects and all of that weren't
gonna be the thing that sells this that
it had to be human that it had to be
true and we had to be saying something
valuable and for someone of his age to
get that and I and I got that from him
right off the bat I thought of course
I'd love to go on this on this journey
with him if I can add to that
I mean descripted evolved totally after
I met Patrick and and Troy and they both
were so vital to be the creation of what
I feel is the final product so thank you
yeah it's something that you don't often
get to do I think when you make these
films because there's so much pressure
to get it right
out there and we actually took we were
gonna shoot it earlier at one point and
then I was couldn't do it because I was
just my timeline wasn't gonna work and
so if there was a period of time when I
wasn't gonna be in the film even though
we had spent six months talking about it
and I was happy to just hand it off and
go go make your movie reality didn't
months later like now we still got to do
this so the day tide you know god bless
them they delayed for a little bit and
then we shot it in March and we met Troy
who is one of the creative pillars of
this film yeah yeah Troy and I spent a
good portion of our of our honeymoon
working on Clark yeah and I don't she
was she she was officially gonna be in
it by that point yes there was a few
weeks before perhaps right and we were
we were like - we were like right doing
writing sessions with the Kosh back and
forth like from our from Bombay from
Bali yeah that's crazy that's shows you
how passionate you were about the
project yeah we really cared and they
were kind enough to sort of welcome us
on as producers and I think they could
sense that we wanted to be respectful of
the process and just help Akash tell his
story but we also felt like we had
something to bring to it especially if
we're gonna play the characters that we
really wanted them to be grounded we
wanted to make the stakes as high as
possible for them and we just wanted to
like help Akash navigate what's the kind
of complex emotional story and it's a
lot of science there's a lot of
different things going on and we just
tried to be defenders of the like what
story are we telling how are these
characters being served where are they
going at every moment and and you know
it was always we're all always on the
same page and it's difficult to welcome
new people creative people into a
process but they were always great about
it I'm realizing that I had three
questions I was just gonna ask and I
realised all three I can't ask because
no one has seen the movie so it's so
offline question right it's like what
have you seen it you know I totally saw
yeah yeah it's all it's all stuff that I
can't ask about so let's move backward
thank you for not I was like asking
about memorable moments from filming so
for each of you what's a day or two that
you will always remember forever about
the making of the film I had the flu
twice while shooting this I don't
remember
it's kind of in a fog but it was
freezing and really cold I remember
others is there's a scene out
on the bench and there's a lot of
monologues or a couple of months in the
movie that are quite long and when
you're on this kind of crunch schedule
and so much is going on you're really
gonna get one or two takes at them and I
was panicked because there's this very
long very important emotional scene on a
bench out in the dark in the middle of
winter we're freezing I think I was
wearing like 300 layers and and I knew
we had like two takes at it we had two
takes and it was very nervous about that
because on suits I'm so used to you know
three-page scenes that we can shoot for
six and a half hours and this was like
we gotta go so I wasn't totally ready
for that but it did that thing that
happens when you're on a project that's
supposed to that's just working so well
where everything just sort of happens
the way exactly the way it's supposed to
happen
yeah that's actually I think my favorite
scene yeah it turned out beautifully
it's a pivotal scene yeah and it was
just relaxed and it was easy and
everybody was prepared and did their job
and that's when you feel really lucky to
do what we do when you're on a set and
you're like you know everybody has to do
their job at the exact right time in the
exact right way otherwise you're not
gonna get the scene and that's what's so
exciting about making movies like this
but can also be the most frustrating
part because if it doesn't work you're
like oh god yep you know three more
weeks of you know messing things up and
every day on this was just got better
and better and tighter and tighter and
tighter I'll go next we shot a scene
which you'll remember where his
character is looking at a giant display
of a like a telescope yes imaging which
looks like you're at a like Caltech
facility and we shot that in a like a
Transit Authority building traffic film
which works as the telescope is actually
a giant traffic monitoring station in
real life but that you could tell I
could not tell it looked so beautiful
the way that our department put it
together it really added a lot of
production value and I just I loved that
scene yeah that was a good day one of
the things that I liked is that I'm not
a big fan of learning I'm not good at
but I actually took away like I learned
stuff about astronomy
the detecting like you did a really good
job at layering in like like teaching
without like making it too difficult if
that makes any sense so did you ever
think about being a teacher I actually
did a year and a half of a B ed before I
dropped out and wanted to make movies so
I was gonna be a teacher and yeah I mean
I think this is my way of sharing that
kind of stuff and yeah in the film
honestly what I really want people to
take away from this are people who don't
know astronomy that well and I want to
kind of you know bring them closer to it
so I'm sure the experts will appreciate
some of the tiny details but really what
I want general audiences to know that
really cool stuff art is happening with
astronomy right now yeah I still want to
talk about stuff in the third act and I
can't but that's the other thing you
mentioned it earlier about like but it's
it really for me it was like a realistic
portrayal of what could you know and all
the science in the film is I mean yeah
he's so on point about it all and a lot
of our preparation was just sending each
other like like articles that would come
out and yes that what happened to my god
you see this Carol can we include it can
you believe that this is real it was all
totally real
the week we started shooting our film
NASA announced that big discovery
Trappist one with seven new planets
exoplanets and three of them are
potentially habitable like that happened
the week we started reading that was
probably the greatest evidence boost
because using the same techniques that
are using in the film and all the
techniques that we described yeah we do
processes and we sat with witnessed a
lot of time with some PHP going over all
the science and making sure that it
checked out and making sure that when
they saw this film they wouldn't know
like oh here we go another you know
Hollywood thing going on like they they
all totally signed off on what we were
talking about which is exciting I just
realized how much you love interstellar
and I realized who was just here
yeah it just occurred to me why aren't
you listening to interstellar on the way
here that when I don't realize Hans
Zimmer was just was
right here so it's funny yeah well
actually when I first wrote this script
I was listening to the interstellar
soundtrack so yeah Chris Nolan like you
kind of changed the course of my life
everyone has been coming in to the
studio except for Hans because we didn't
have enough time has been playing get to
know your TIF attendee I swear to you
these are harmless questions you do not
have to be nervous for you what TV show
would you love to guest spot on what TV
show would you love to guest direct and
what TV show would you love to guest
produce no pressure
currently airing or can be anything you
want so you can go back and back in town
you shouldn't do that the topic I think
I'm gonna go to the Duce right now I
think David Simon's the deuce is pretty
amazing I don't know what part I'd play
but the acting and the writing on that
shows incredible
I would definitely guess direct it maybe
further down the line like I spin off a
game of Thrones or something like that I
was gonna say the same thing I would
love to produce an episode of Game of
Thrones just to get the experience of
managing like two concurrent giant
productions at the same time and to
cruise in different countries at the
exact same time do you a favorite sci-fi
or fantasy film I'm gonna say contact
off the top of my head just because it's
been on my mind recently I just think in
terms of grounded sci-fi it's such a
beautiful moving film yeah I would have
said contact so let's do your thunder
interstellar I got to say it yeah yeah
but he took took mine so I'll go a
little lighter probably the fifth
element yes back to the future
just for bonus points yeah of course
what film scared you as a kid
Cujo killer dog
Jurassic Park the first one for me it
was all of the Nightmare on Elm Street
franchise is there anything that you
collect cameras do you film cameras it's
just filmers also digit film can I have
a couple of digital cameras put film
cameras yeah
rocks and minerals definitely our
science person I have a collection of
pocket knives goes back a long time
cool do you own any movie movie or TV
show props you borrow anything from the
set of anything you've worked on Hans
I was I was murdered on a show called
luck sure Michael Gambon murdered me
with a glass ashtray so I have the
ashtray and I also have my severed head
from that show which was also used I
have it in a box in my basement I just
use it to scare people sometimes yeah I
mean I get I kept a lot of props from
the film so did you keep the clapboard
sorry which one do you know the oh no no
they didn't let me yeah I kept the Dylan
album oh yes for people that don't
realize that Bob Dylan plays a key role
in this movie I have lots of props and
things from films that I've made think I
think including these pants were from
Clara those pants too yeah what TV show
have you watched all the way through
more than once The Sopranos that's every
show Breaking Bad what's the background
photo on your phone I can't say what
movie have you watched more than 20
times Pulp Fiction Forrest Gump School
of Rock do you have a favorite pair of
sneakers or shoes I do but I'm not
wearing today but yes I do I have a
trusted pair that I
Monday to Friday every week do you want
to give a shout-out to the brand yeah
what's a brand their route go Canada
Canada Red Wings I have some Red Wings
I've had for probably about six years
I got Rockport's Rockport's yeah do you
do you remember when you were growing up
what made you want to get involved in
the entertainment industry like what was
that thing if there was just that one
thing for me it was it was just telling
stories for me as a kid I surrounded
myself in film and theater and
television I it was where I went to feel
better it's where I went to feel a part
of a community I just it was like church
for me watching how stories unfold it's
all the different kinds of stories and
and learning that that was something
that you could actually do for a living
was was the pole I thought well there's
nothing in the world that I want to do
more than that for me I grew up in the
industry my mother's an actress my
father's a producer so I was exposed to
it my whole life and from a very early
age I chose to gravitate towards the
producing side not the acting side but
it was just something that I was sort of
fascinated by from a very young age and
had a lot of exposure to sort of I got
to pick up the business side of it in
addition to the creative side of it and
as I got older it just became something
that I really wanted to do and I had a
you know a great tutor and my father so
I got to ask him all the questions that
you you never learn about in film school
yeah so that's it before you answer with
the fact that you wanted to possibly be
in like you know or interested in acting
if you will have you ever thought about
doing like the Hitchcock thing where
you're walking by in your films that you
produce you were never in this film
right I didn't know I'm BG in the film
that some you aren't okay I'm deep deep
background but yes I do
cameos in all of my films you'll see me
and some of them many times but deep
accra yeah what was your what got you
into it I had the original trilogy of
Star Wars on VHS and those were like the
first live-action movies I've ever seen
and immediately as from like the
youngest age nu I want to make
my last question for you guys
Clara's part of the Toronto Film
Festival my favourite festival I love
this one what does it mean for each of
you to be a part of this fest and with
such amazing movies well we're all from
I'm from Toronto yeah we both went to
high school together actually I mean
i-i've sat and lived in Toronto trama
been a part of my life forever I've
watched the festival come through town
my whole life and go away and as that
somebody wanted to be an actor and then
became an actor and then was here
shooting a show I've always sort of
watched the festival come and watch it
go oh man that would be great to be a
part of it so for me this is a it's a
bucket list it stream come true and to
be here with a film that we shot in
Toronto with Canadians that it is a that
is sort of a part of the beating heart
of Canadian film is it's such an honor
and I feel very grateful ya know i
Edmonton and and TIFF has always kind of
been what it's the biggest festival in
Canada and maybe even the world Film
Festival so as a filmmaker this is a
dream come true happening right now so
yeah yeah for me I mean I've had other
films and Tiff's in the past but for
this particular film you know TIFF
really does provide a platform and an
opportunity for a film like this to be
discovered and to launch into the into
the marketplace in a meaningful way so
we're really grateful to TIFF for
selecting us and giving us the
opportunity to premiere in front of a
big audience and you know talk to people
like you and help launch our film you
know nobody's seen it we haven't shown
it to anybody yet so this is a really
important festival for us and it means a
lot we're happy to be here I was gonna
say even more grateful that I got to see
it prior to you guys coming in I didn't
realise buyers haven't even seen it yet
you know anyway listen Thank You Ellis
of Aurora for letting me do this
interview and for being a great sponsor
and sincerely congratulations
thank you for having me
[Music]
you